like what the actual percentages of men
that make over a certain amount but so
do you think do you think you're in the
top 20 percent of females to get that so
funny it is in one financially no just
like in what man value which is like
femininity Beauty it starts with looks
femininity Beauty do you think you're
the top 20 of females
if
I then you probably would be dating a be
dating a guy that makes less
could be a problem if you couldn't
submit to a guy that dates less do you
think that would cause issues in a
relationship
it would yeah I'm just talking from
experience from what I've observed from
other people's marriages yeah yeah what
do you think
yeah I think it most likely would yeah
it would yeah
um
so what's the question
so since since let's say 20 of men make
over that yeah
um which is going to fact check because
I wasn't sure but
do you think you're in the top 20 of
females
I'd like to believe so but um
I don't know why not I think so maybe
top 20 of females
I mean it would help
females are in the top 20 that you would
give examples so that they can get okay
okay okay so um I mean Kevin Samuels
always says Beyonce is an eight
okay so do you think you're as pretty as
Beyonce no
Kelly I don't really think Beyonce is
that pretty in honesty or Rihanna so
um
Rihanna's pretty young yeah
yeah I mean what would you say you're in
that if I had enough money as Rihanna
yeah I think I could be
because she they
funny so so money makes you look better
like if they were normal people
it's very like big things with money
they're there Oprah for example I think
money helps optimize what's there yeah
yeah that's what I mean yeah but
typically I was going to say it like is
it being fit and it's a feminine and
friendly yeah I have all that but I'm
not fit yet I'm working towards it
and it goes by facial symmetry so the
way I look at it is like most people are
average right so I do four like and I
kind of take it I'm gonna give credits I
know in the comments they'll be like
credit Kevin Samuels yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I know I know I know I
always think of like eight is the
prettiest girl in a small town nine
means you make it to Hollywood based on
your looks 10 is damn near perfect so
nines and tens they'll make it to
Hollywood AIDS it's the prettiest girl
in a small town I don't really give out
like sevens because you have to pick are
you are you beautiful gorgeous or are
you cute
and and so most people are four fives
and sixes they're pretty or cute
yeah I'm average I think okay yeah I
definitely say I'm like an average four
maybe or something yeah okay
um that's that's humble like that I get
credit just a fact well I don't know a
lot of girls a lot of girls come on and
say 10 so go ahead yeah no I wouldn't
say I'm a 10 but I don't necessarily
think I'm average maybe just a bit
beyond that like like six yeah okay okay
six but like I this is just a common
problem that I see in relationships is
like as average girls we want above
average guys and then we can't submit to
the guys that are on our level
um
oh he just dropped
um yeah these are because like average
is 35 000 what's the average income in
London or it might be 45 but we we set
up to 70. we set up to 70 to fully
commit which is I'm not knocking you for
it I think a lot of people would say the
same things I guess when you say fully
commit for us submits yeah submit is
like you've given all yourself away yeah
so it's like it's I guess it's a hard
thing to grasp because I guess we live
in an environment where that's not cool
or not really yeah yeah
well it's like there can't be two there
can't be two CEOs in a house someone has
to lead yeah have you ever been in a
relationship where you had felt like you
had to lead yeah yeah I had to end those
like taking you take Initiative for
goodness sake yeah what do you yeah same
I just
it just feels like you're the man yeah
yeah and very uncomfortable yeah it does
not feel you don't feel safe yeah yeah
oh the same yeah
and I'm curious from the guys have you
ever had experiences where the women
like tried to lead
in this country yeah yeah I mean um it's
um you get you get a lot of women who
have a very strong male energy and they
want to lead even in dancing we're doing
salsa like love I'm I have to do this
hold on and they're like try to make
moves I'm like no this then this was a
reflection of the relationship where
they were constantly I'm like look I'll
make this decision I'll make this call
how about next time you make the call
and then and so on we're talking small
things like one time we went into a bar
and um I made the decision of the drinks
well I mean I didn't make the decision
I'm like you're drinking this I said
this is a really nice drink I drink it
all the time would you like to try it
and she liked that but then again other
times it was always like a little bit of
pushback on on on things that I said
look I know what well what I'm doing
here is okay I got this but it was a
constant you know push and pull and
that's I think it is because of women
have very strong you know some women
have very strong male energy
because with the submission thing like
the intangible things that I look for is
can you take Initiative for me I find it
hard to find a guy who wants to take
initiative you ask me out and then you
ask me to plan the date like no [__] no
bye I'm not doing that like I've dealt a
couple of
um girls who maybe you know maybe try to
lead in certain things or whatever and
it's weird and this is some game for the
guys
um I said to one of my friends he was
considering buying his first place with
his girlfriend I said don't do it he was
like your first place as a man should be
yours and I'll give you this story as to
why there was a girl who I was dating at
one point where she stayed with me for
like a couple of weeks and I owned my
own home and stuff
um and when she was staying she was
trying to make certain decisions for the
households
and then it was like we went away on
holiday and stuff and we drove you know
my car and everything
I know certain decisions she was trying
to make and I was like you know I'm a
I'm a nice guy like I'm reasonable do
you know what I mean but then it did get
to a point where I had to be like
you're in my house
this is my house everything I've sorted
for us I've done for us right so if I'm
not okay with something it's not
happening
I wouldn't be able to do that
if
there was
co-ownership
and it's not about necessarily having
control but I think as as a man part of
the when we say Authority it's almost
like you almost have to have that
Authority on paper because you don't
want to have to play that card if
someone's trying to violate you
but you can play it if you need to does
that make sense so it's one of those
things where it's like
that's the only time where I realized
that if I wasn't in that position
then there could have been even more of
a clash but it was like you know I was
like look with Audio Express like this
is my place like what kind of things
what's she doing sure Type move some
furniture around show it to like I'm
thinking you've been here a week like
um
she was like you know saying she was
saying stuff about
how uh something about how oh she was
like wanting to cook and stuff and she
was saying that I didn't often the
reason I didn't offer because I had a
session with the client and she was
saying oh you've not helped in this I
was like I'm sorry who got us here who
booked the hotel who did this this and
this and like when it's logistically
true like you can't argue with that so I
think um that's the only time
where maybe she was somebody who's used
to being a masculine China leader she
tried to lead in that sense and that was
that was the only that was the only
efficient way I think a man maybe can
kind of re-establishing himself in that
position if that's where he wants to be